so trump's wechat ban could touch
everything from spotify to league of
legends
wechat's band mate may be a bigger deal
than tick tocks
maybe no it will be and i think what
we're seeing in the language
a lot of people are saying trump maybe
made a mistake with the executive order
because it bans transactions with
tencent
check this out so yeah so immediately
they bring they bring all the stuff up
we get the contact but look at this
here's a non-exhaustive list of the
companies and properties that tencent
owns or has investments in
riot games league of legends they've got
forty percent stake in
uh uh epic games eighty percent of
supercell
clash of clans let's see there they
publishes the mobile version of pick up
player unknown battlegrounds in china
and they own eleven percent of blue hole
single-digit stakes in studios like
blizzard ubisoft and platinum games
there's another tencent messaging app
called qq with several several hundred
million
users that predates wechat their
production company and distributor
tencent pictures
is involved in major hollywood
productions like wonder woman venom
terminator dark fate
and top gun maverick it also acts as a
major film distributor
with within china and owns minority
stakes in a range of smaller production
companies
they struck a 1.5 billion dollar
five-year deal with the nba
to stream its games in china snap
owner of snapchat sold 12 to 10 cent
2017.
they own 14 of cacao which is a gaming
platform i guess in south korea
they bought a 10 stake in universal
music group wow
they have nine per they have a nine
percent stake in spotify with the two
uh with the two partnering on tencent
music in china
let me let me read you the executive
order the provision one says
they say in this verge article the
order's language is broad
invoking the international emergency
economic powers act to prohibit quote
any transaction that is related to
wechat by any person
or with respect to any property subject
to the jurisdiction of the united states
with tencent holdings ltd or any
subsidiary of that entity
as identified by the secretary of
commerce they mentioned they bolded it
themselves
we don't know how strict the department
of commerce will be about enforcing that
rule until the enforcement starts let me
just say
it prohibits any transaction that is
related to wechat by any person
or with respect to any property subject
to the jurisdiction of the u.s with
tencent holdings that includes reddit
yeah so doesn't that mean you can't you
know
have in-app purchases anymore for league
of legends fortnite all these
you know what else what i mean it's
beyond that it's modified it's gonna
it's going to ban all of these companies
yeah well i mean well what does that
mean for the nba deal too 1.5 billion
dollars
well no wonder this they are in love
with china first and foremost the white
house clarified saying no no
no it's just in relation to wechat so
what does that mean
what is it what does that mean so so if
reddit makes a transaction some way
related to wechat
they they like they can't do that now
how how could something be related to
each ad does reddit post the wechat
symbol on links like you know a lot of
websites like an article will have the
wechat symbol
does every single news website now have
to remove the wechat symbol
if they i don't know i don't know how
many you actually use it but you like
post the link or something yeah
they're gonna they're gonna cut it off
and i think this is intentionally vague
a lot of people are saying trump made a
mistake it's overly broad on accident no
way
no he doesn't make mistakes well it's
not just that it's like it's the federal
government
they're they're gonna tell you don't
worry don't worry we're only going after
wechat
take it all yeah right and so they're
gonna go after tencent
and i think i think the reason why
they're what they're trying to say
with with how this restricts tencent
would be like
if i own two different companies and one
of the companies needs to pay me
but i have to pay a different company i
can have that company just pay the other
company you know what i mean
like if bob owes if adam owes me 10
bucks and i own lydia
oh lydia 10 bucks adam said you know i
say oh just give the ten bucks to lydia
so it doesn't even go to me right right
you could theoretically do that with
wechat
so they make this overly broad executive
order
so that if tencent try saying we need to
get money to wechat how do we do it i
know
we'll have reddit pay for the it
services
at a warehouse that has some wechat but
no one's paying wechat at all
but they'll still benefit from it or
they'll use that nba money
to pay for you know services that host
the sites
instead of wechat doing it but then it's
it's just coming from that nba
exactly so i i own several companies
you know theoretically like let's say i
bought a warehouse
i could be like here i'll allocate this
spot to this company
no one's trained no no one's exchanging
any money there's no you know but
that's how you know you could
theoretically get that value to that
company
so it seems like yes this absolutely
will be having a massive impact beyond
what anybody
anybody thought was going to happen oh
yeah and you know the best part is
here we go photo surfaces showing tick
tock executives posing with communist
flag oh my goodness so this is the other
company that that
uh that trump you know banned bite dance
so bite dance isn't as big of a deal it
is because tick tock was so big
yeah but i mean you think about tencent
man if they're not actually going after
tencent and they're only going after
wechat
i just got to say this first first of
all take a look at this come on the
tic-tac people posing with the communist
flag okay okay it's a little over the
top
but take a look at all these companies
and i got i gotta wonder
if if you've got people playing league
of legends i mean all their private data
is is in league of legends too like
china still has access to all that
information
maybe not the same as a phone but
they're on they're on your computer
what if league of legends which they own
they have 100
of riot games wow what if you open up
league of legends and it's running in
the background stealing you're stealing
your stuff
you wouldn't know you would not know
listen man people don't get it
currently there's over five million
registered players
in league of legends yeah it's a lot of
people so why isn't trump banning them
why isn't he saying no to all of it and
shutting it all down maybe he is
maybe people don't realize it yeah but
i'll tell you what man
you got a mobile device and you got tic
tac tic tock or wechat and they can
steal your information without you
knowing it they really can you would
never know it
and we're talking about how dangerous
that is i think it's worse that they're
going to be on your computer your
desktop or laptop computer
if you're playing video games i'll tell
you what man
people don't realize how easy it is to
create software
custom order so you know
having friends in the hacker community
there are people you could pay
and and and you shouldn't because this
is illegal or actually i'll put it this
way
there are penetration testers that's
what's called pen testing okay
and you can hire them if you're a
company and you say i want to make sure
we have the best security possible
so we've bolstered our cyber security
then they hire someone to write a custom
program to bypass that and steal your
information undetected
and they can do it custom order you know
there was a new game
i believe it's by epic i don't know
exactly but
while i was looking through this one of
these companies valerian have you heard
of that
i think so so when that first came out
they had this anti-hacking
software that for you to even run the
game
you had to have it install and it it
when you booted your computer up it
turned on
so you couldn't even get around it it
was like as you booted your computer up
you had to like reset your computer so
it can boot on
with this anti-hacking software for just
to play because it's one of their first
person shooter games
so it was under the guise of
anti-hacking so you can't hack the side
right
isn't it but we're finding out that a
lot of these
chinese systems are actually spying on
us
so that that scares me you know i don't
i doubt it's just anti-hacking now you
know my favorite
conspiracy theory is what that your
toaster is spying on you is that
i'm not kidding there was a there was a
big scare
that our hard appliances that are made
in china like toasters
will have bluetooth or wi-fi chips
programmed to
take in data and then what what they
would do is they would brute force
a local uh internet you know router yeah
and send the data back to china
oh wow so i don't know if that stuff's
true because i talked to some security
experts who said
it was paranoia in the in the you know
the us government and the military
but apparently they said there was some
rule where it's like certain government
entities couldn't buy products made in
china i think it still may be the case
hey so didn't the ussr literally get a
big old seal into the
oval office with a listening device
behind it at one point i have no idea
that
yeah that's my understanding i don't
look it up but there but they've been
listening that way for a long time so i
just checked
that 10 cent owns 100 of riot games yeah
riot games
owns valerian the video game so that
anti-hackings
is 100 owned by 10 cent which is 100
chinese which now we now know they were
using tic-tac to get our information
or tick-tock so i was talking i would
not play that game if i were you get
that off your system
it might be too late there was a back in
the day there was this really funny
thing you could download called like
sheep
okay and what it would do is on your
desktop a little sheep would walk around
and you could like drag it and throw it
and it was just a fun little background
graphic that's dope
you so people you'd pick it up and you
it would like climb on folders
it'll be like walking on your windows
and people loved it turned out it was a
virus
oh it was a trick everybody wanted it so
everybody installed it and it gave back
door access to some hackers or i i oh
man that's the story as i remember it
when it came to these toasters that were
spying on us i was told by security
expert the reality was
the us government wanted an excuse to
spend money on american-made products
and bolster american companies over
china so they said your toaster is
spying on you your toaster it's gonna
you know download your your internet or
you know secret information and so then
they took these this grant money and
said okay we got to go in and get rid of
all of the chinese toasters and
microwaves and refrigerators
and buy american and that was the real
reason for it
i'll tell you what man i think i
wouldn't be surprised
it's not hard to do you know these these
chips like wi-fi chips people don't
really
they're tiny yeah you can get them real
small i mean look at a cell phone
you can put a tiny little antenna in
there good point and i'm telling you man
it's really easy
to there are programs that can it's
called brute force a brute force attack
which is
basically what it does is it sends every
possible combination of passwords to the
machine until it finds it
if you get a really good password it
could take forever yeah but i'll tell
you what man i've seen some crazy stuff
back in my day
in spain during these big protests this
was back in like 2012
someone reverse engineered the algorithm
of a local telecom
okay so what happens is when people
bought the routers
the router would have a name it would
say you know like telecom 97
you know 1a2 and then they would they
reverse engineered it so that
if the because the password was based on
the name
so they figured out the algorithm and
then you could type in the name of the
router and it would generate the
password for you
so then what they did was someone made
an app that when you were walking
down when you were walking anywhere your
phone would constantly jump to any open
router or any any
any router period because it would just
figure that instantly reverse engineer
the password
wow and so they were using that for live
streaming when the cell when the cell
infrastructure went down
think about how easy it is for some
ragtag you know lefties to reverse
engineer a company's you know router
you better believe china had access a
long time ago we're talking about
a massive power a powerful you know
country with
military technology and they're gonna be
i i mean i'll tell you what man
i'd be willing to bet china already
knows has access to everything
i would absolutely bet you know they
have access to every single one of our
in our systems
all our passwords people don't realize
it is not hard
yep you know you know you know what uh p
people do
the easiest thing they'll take a usb
stick
with a virus on it and they'll just
chuck it at a bank door
bounce on the ground hit the ground and
they walk away and you know what happens
they plug it in to see what's up
somebody will walk up and go oh what's
this they'll pick it up and they'll put
on their computer boom infect the whole
network
and there's nothing you can do about
that because people just don't know
yeah so you end up with making it very
easy
for i mean theoretically check this out
we have
you know usb uh memory drives and flash
drives yeah made in china
it's a good point they could easily hide
simple software that you're buying it
you pop up in the package and you're
like it's a clean buy i bought it from
the store and boom you put it in and
everything is made in china yup apple
like microsoft like all these the top
tech companies
everything's made in china so what's
stopping them from
adding a little bit of you know a little
chip here and there just so they can
maybe one day just flick the switch and
be like all right now we can see
every single thing on every single one
of these devices that that
message from trump the other day that
ominous statement yeah and now
now where is he bedminster yeah
bedminster in new jersey and what what
is that
it's his uh bunker getaway spot yeah
he's got like a little oh
it's a golf course sure under the golf
course
he's been secretly building a bunk over
the past several years i'm sure
no i'm sure it's been there for decades
come on
come on no what's the what's that what's
the effect of it what's the official
reason he's there for a vacation
yeah just there for the weekend i think
no way just for the weekend they said
why would he have told
the public yesterday you're not gonna
you're not gonna see him of course
today he has a press conference well
yeah we weren't able to finish watching
it because we had to go live today but
i wanna now i to go watch it when i'm
done a lot of people have hit me up and
been like oh he totally burned the media
and it's like ooh
he always does he always does but i
missed it thanks for checking out this
clip from the tim cast irl podcast we do
the show
live monday through friday at 8 p.m if
you want to catch the full show
tune in to this channel subscribe hit
the like button or
check us out on itunes and spotify and
we will soon have this podcast up for
free
on all podcast platforms thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next episode